rêve largement partagé symbole
d'ascenseur social l'accession à la
propriété est aujourd'hui menacée et
elle doit être relancée plusieurs
voudraient masquer les difficultés
d'accès à la propriété et le manque de
volonté de les surmonter certains
expliquent que les jeunes générations
seraient maintenant tourné vers
l'économie du partage et de l'usage
plutôt que de la propriété et qu'ell ne
souharait plus devenir propriétaire cela
me laisse dubitative en France la
décohabit tion des jeunes était jusqu'à
jusqu'à récemment la plus précoce en
Europe marquant une saine volonté
d'indépendance sa régression récente
dénote en réalité de graves problèmes
économiques et d'entrée dans la vie
active certains voudraient aussi
délégitimer toute politique d'accession
à la propriété comme étant directement
synonyme d'étalement urbains et
d'artificialisation des sols ces idées
ont conduit au résultat plus que
décevant du Conseil national de la
refondation sur le logement et qui au
lieu d'aboutir à une relance du secteur
ont servi à justifier de nouvelles
coupes budgétaires dans les aides au
logement sans autre finalité que de
réduire le déficit personne n'en est
dupe parmi celle-ci ce qui est
publiquement appelé le rentrage du PTZ
du prêt à taux zé porte un coût direct
aux capacités d'accession à la propriété
de très nombreux ménages il y a 6 ans
maintenant en 2017 il en avait été de
même avec laap accession alors qu'était
dans le même temps promu la vente de
logements sociaux à leurs occupants ici
nous n'avons eu de cess sur les rangs de
la majorité sénatoriale de remettre la
pacession qui n'a été malheureusement à
chaque fois que enlevé par l'Assemblée
nationale quel dommage pour tous ces
ménages modestes qui ne peuvent plus
bénéficier de ce coup de pouce notre
groupe crois au contraire que
l'accession à la propriété est un
objectif qui mérite d'être de nouveau
promu par les pouvoirs publics